i thought i should acknowledge how much
confusion there is
right now in the country about what
we're supposed to do
there's so much confusion about how we
should be reacting to covid19
a lot of mixed signals from public
officials the president says one thing
many governors say another thing even
the nation's top public health agency
the cdc
has been inconsistent check it out in
march the cdc said
we didn't have to wear masks now they're
saying we do
well i looked into it and a lot of
recommendations on the cdc's covid19
website
are confusing for example check this out
they're saying
wash your hands for 20 seconds or 5
seconds if no one's
watching look at this if someone sneezes
near you
punch the air that's
yes if you win at rock paper scissors
the other person gets the virus and you
don't
you can hook up with a stranger in a bar
as long as you remain
emotionally distant well i'm safe
since small children are low risk for
contracting covid it is acceptable to
use a baby
as a protective face mask that's wrong
i shouldn't please don't pay attention
to that one
run run and never come back are you
listening to me
you have to disappear get out of here go
now
if you used your time during quarantine
to write a novel
learn mandarin or do anything productive
just know that
everyone hates you although it is only
one of many reasons not to go near
clowns please be aware that all clowns
have coronavirus
you can't get coveted in a hot tub or
was it you can't get pregnant
let's say both and also my parents are
out of town this weekend
and finally although there's a low
likelihood of spreading covid while
jogging without a mask
at least put on a shirt you animal
well good luck figuring those out as i
said
very confusing